こんにちわ
こんばんわはじめしゃちょーだよ
皆
ロウソク
アツッ！
皆、ロウソク好きかね
あぁぁ、ロウソクきれいだね
こう
アッツ！
こんなたくさんロウソクあると
さぁここ迄で皆さん気づいているかどうかは分かりませんが、
このロウソク全て
FAKE★
お分かりでしょうかでも分かってる人もいそうなんだけど
これね偽物なんですよ
後ろが電源式になってて、こうやってつけるとめちゃくちゃロウソクに見えるっていう置物です
そんな偽物のロウソクを300個買いました
ウェェェ↑↑↑↑↑↑
さすがにこんなに置くと何かチカチカしてバレると思うんですけどもぉ
普通に一個だけポイッて置いといたらマジでロウソクに見えるんですよ
いや、本当は本物でやりたかったんですけどもぉすいませんね
最近YouTubeさんが厳しくて
おそらく家でこんだけ本物のロウソク焚いたらもう火事みたいになっちゃうんで
「ダメです」
というわけで偽物を準備させていただきました
アッ♂ツくないんですよねぇ
さぁ、こんなたくさんのロウソクを使って何をするかといいますと
ロウソクといえども、火は火
例えばこれがですよ、本物のロウソクでチョ↑っとこう椅子とかについたら椅子燃えますからね
そう、ロウソクの火だといってもとっても危険
はい、というわけで今回何をするかといいますと
ま、偽物だからこそできるドッキリしようと思います
後輩のけんすけが今家の前に車止まってるんで
その車の中にこの大量の300個のロウソクを何かこういい感じに配置しておきます
そしてロウソクを設置し終わった後ターゲットを車に呼びます
と言って彼が車に戻った瞬間車の中を見てみると
もしこれが本物でこれだけのロウソク車にあったら間違いなく燃えます★
透明のこのロウソク見たらマジで本物だと思うんで
はたして、車の中が大量のロウソクだらけだったらどういう反応をするのか
検証していきたいと思います
皆、ぜぇぇったい、本物のロウソクでやらないでねマジで本当に燃えるから本当に！
偽物だったら、いいよ★
やばいやばいやばい！やばい！やばいやばいやばい！
やばいｗ
これｗ
やばいｗ待ってｗ
光がすごすぎるｗ
そしてあいつはこのドッキリをするのに最適なところがある
あの男
はい、というわけで早速ガンガン置いていきましょう
夕暮れはまだ来ないんで、暗くなる前になるべく設置できればなと思います
どんどん仕掛けていきましょう
そう、あの男ね、車のカギかけなすぎなんすよね
なんでこれを機にね、車のカギちゃんとかけなきゃなって思ってくれると嬉しいです
今近所の人に会ったんですけど、本物ですかって間違われました
これは引っかかりますね★
はーぴばーすでーいとぅーゆー
はい、というわけでご覧下さい
車の中でぇす
ほぉｗ明るいでぇすｗはっはっはｗ
いやぁ、でもちょっとテンション上がりますね
普通のイルミネーションだったらテンション上がるんですけども
乗ってる本人はこれがねもう本物のロウソクだと思って来るんで
マジで焦ると思います
さぁ、まるで300歳の誕生日を迎えてしまったようなターゲットの車
これを見た瞬間はたしてターゲットは何と言うのでしょうか
分からないです
非常に気になるところです
では暗くなってダーゲットが来るのを待ちましょう
け）どうしたんすか？
待って
は）え、待って、ロウソク？これ
け）待って、本当どうする？これ
え？
ねぇ
は）ガチでやばいって　け）ガチでやばいって
は）ガチでロウソクやん
け）え！
え！
え？
は）というわけで、車の中がロウソクで燃え盛ってるドッキリでしたぁ
け）すごｗｗｗｗ
け）マジで死んだと思った